aujourd'hui débute la semaine de la
mobilité à saint quentin en yvelines au
programme animations dans les
entreprises et enquête sur le réseau
stibus mais aussi un jeu la chasse au
but cinq bus ont été rénovés et arbore
les nouvelles couleurs de saint quentin
en yvelines le but c'est bien sûr de les
prouver pour cela il faut ouvrir l'oeil
et capturé en images est l'un de ces
cinq véhicules
la photo est à poster sur les réseaux
sociaux avec le hashtag sky la vue un
tirage au sort aura lieu à la fin de
l'opération et le jeu est ouvert
jusqu'au 15 octobre
je vous propose d'écouter à michel
augier le président de saint quentin en
yvelines nous en dire un peu plus sur
cette semaine de la mobilité douce ou
est-on à travers cette semaine a bien
proposé à tous les usagers un petit peu
les services qui sont apportées tout au
long de l'année par l'agglomération
et puis surtout mettre à l'eau d'heure
bien sûr tous ceux qui travaillent on
met des moyens pour que justement et
puis se prendre quelques quelques
minutes et bien comprendre aujourd'hui
toutes les possibilités qui leur sont
offertes